[Music]
speaking of scoring Jamal Crawford NBA
Sixth Man of the Year three times played
for nine teams over 20 Seasons I believe
scored over 50 points coming off the
bench and maybe didn't have an assist in
that game is that right did did Jamal
score 51 or something and then he had no
assists I I think he had two assists oh
two assists I had five assist no you
didn't you didn't have
five go look it up there okay look up
the box score all right well welcome
Jamal we're talking scoring here um you
know now it's 60 a night not a big deal
even 70 doesn't feel like a big deal
tell us why we've had so much individual
scoring and so much team
scoring well I think it's a combination
of things obviously I think Talent from
1 to 12 is up across the board board but
I also think the defender is a little
bit handicapped uh you can't really
touch a person you can't you know it's
freedom of movement with the everybody
wants to see the skills of the players
but the points right now are just it's
unbelievable though I think the power of
the three-point shot and the fact that
everybody can shoot the three-point shot
as far as being allowed to it used to be
some restraint you know like it's
reserved for guys who can really shoot
it now you have role players taking 14
15 threes in the game and that helps
scoring as well is somebody going to get
to
90 no I hope not come on Dan I but it
it's tough I mean you see 70 just
getting thrown up 70s like the new 50
but is it bad is it bad for the game
that we're seeing
7073 and we're not really blinking at
it I I think it's bad for the game that
it's happening this often okay if it was
you know an anomaly and happened once a
year it would be something to really be
revered now it's happen so often you
don't know when it's going to happen I'm
not sure how good that is for the game
to happen this off well Luca had 73 and
took 33 shots and normally if you're
going to be putting up those kind of
points you're going to be putting up a
lot more shots than that and you know
what I told my son I said how many
points did Luka score tonight he said 73
I said but did you notice he had 14
assists as well and he's like oh I said
because scores whenever you can score
like that and then you can pass like
that you put the defense in the trick
bag it's not like I said if he only had
five assists he may have 55 points but
the fact that he can score and pass he's
manipulating the game and he's doing at
the highest level right now so you think
Kobe's 81 is
safe I think it's safe I hope it's safe
because that 81 was against it was
against the Zone against three Defenders
go back and look at the spacing and how
tough those those makes were on the
81-point night yeah we we need to
appreciate that for sure it always felt
like he had tougher shots he made tough
tougher shots than anybody I remember is
that fair I mean I don't know if I'm
overrating or exaggerating here but it
felt like Kobe they were tough tough
makes they were tough tough makes for
everybody but Kobe he he did them he
practiced you know that way I I heard
one story one of his trainers told me
one time Kobe was working out and he
wanted the trainer to foul him and the
trainer's fing him he's like no no Hit
Me Harder hit me harder and where the
guy was just basically raped all over
him and Kobe was still making shots so
he practiced that way so for him it was
easy it feels like you got your Allan
Iverson shirt on is is Iverson sort of
taken over where Kobe was with younger
players where that it wasn't their
Jordan I mean he's their Jordan it's not
uh you know Kobe I think while he was
still alive and then Allen Iverson uh is
that true yeah I think those guys in
particular especially for my generation
they really penetrated uh everything
they penetrated culture they penetrated
you know the game the way they played
they did it in a rebellious Fearless
type of way and I think the guys that
are really chasing being Fearless you
know they come from the Kobe Iverson
tree for sure yeah Iverson though man he
just kept coming at you didn't he DP he
just did not stop he was relentless he
didn't care what he was shooting he
didn't care the odds were stacked
against him when they beat the Lakers
and they were you know the one lak lost
the Lakers had that whole playoff run he
was just so Fearless and he made you
believe he had a chance even if you look
at the team he shouldn't have had a
chance uh what do you have Paulie yeah
April 9th 2019 Jamal was that your last
game Phoenix Suns Dallas Mavericks in an
official Arena yes it was it was Dirk's
party but I tried to make it my party as
well yeah you had 51 and five assists I
confuse you with Jimmer fet who had zero
points and Z zero assists that game but
yeah 51 points 18 that was Paulie that
was the only 50-point game I lost and
like I said the there was no way or
walking out there with a win in Dirk's
last home game but that was the only one
I always you know tell my son that you
can score a lot but if you can get
assists as well it makes the game
scoring becomes easier so that's one of
the things I'm I'm hammering home to him
right now he's Jamal Crawford Turner
Sports NBA analyst and won the Sixth Man
of the Year three time did you ever say
I'm the Sixth Man haven't I earned the
starting role with any of these
teams you know what damn when I when I
was starting we weren't winning much and
I didn't like that feeling I'm like you
know what I won in high school I won in
college the games I played I won as a
kid I'll do whatever it takes and the
perfect storm came for me to get traded
right in the middle of my career to a
team that already had a starting unit
symbol so I just owned the six-man I
didn't know it would take on a life of
its own like it has now to see everybody
every gym I go to in the country you
know the six man or that's really really
cool because that was not the plan I did
not grow up saying I wanted to be a
sixth man that's for sure okay but do we
celebrate the sixth man now doesn't seem
like that's as big a deal today's NBA we
don't we don't and I think it's it's
tough because we'll see a guy like Lou
Williams in the past obviously Manu uh
and Kobe madees the All-Star game is a
six-man Kobe has voted in but we'll see
we ask a guy to sacrifice and come off
the bench and when he's sacrificing if
you're a six man you're probably gonna
sacrifice money playing time
endorsements everything that comes with
it but then we don't reward him when
it's that time if he's playing at that
level Lou Williams a few years back was
averaging 20 points Off the Bench he
could have absolutely made the All-Star
game if he was just starting but some
coaches viewed him as off the- bench guy
even though they treated him as a
starter then I saw a crazy stat I think
I'm fourth all time in fourth quarter
points in history since they've been
tracking it as a six man up there with
Kobe LeBron Dirk and I forgot the last
game maybe paully could look it up but
yeah I was I mean as a six man
basically you know I'm wondering as U we
have that minimum you got to play in at
least 65 games MH that could cost Joe
alenbi another MVP because he missed the
game in Denver and then missed the game
in Portland what do you think of that
minimum number of games that you have to
play to be eligible for postseason
Awards well I like I like what they're
trying to do obviously but MB is having
an MVP type season there's no doubt so
if he's one game short of the minimum
with the season he's had and the season
his team is having that's a tough P of
swallow but the way he's playing when he
is playing is dominant like he's Absol
dominant you can make an argument that
could be the third one because he
thought he should have had it the first
year you know even though I'm a huge
huge Joker fan as well well Joker
probably I think it was Bo last year
yeah I think I think it was held against
him that he didn't have postseason
success prior to so he'd won two MVPs
and the voters probably went we can't
give him a threee he hasn't done
anything in the postseason then wins the
you know NBA title now I think voters
look at you know Joker differently
whereas we're waiting for embiid it's
like Lamar Jackson like okay MVP you
can't even get to a championship and I
think that might be held against embiid
this year uh and the number of games
that he's going to miss and speaking of
Joker's greatness last year he could
have won MVP I felt like some criticism
in the media he just took his foot off
the gas and said you know what brother
no problem I'll go win the finals I'll
leave the stats in in points assists
rebounds I'll do it in such a dominant
fashion and I don't even care then I'll
go ride my horses so Joker is a is is a
treat and a gift as well yeah I don't
know if it matters to him I think he's
competitive but I don't I don't know if
it's as important as it is to us that we
think it is I was also wondering about
Doc Rivers took over for the bucks they
lost last night in his debut he said I
wouldn't wish this job on
anybody why nobody's holding a gun to
Doc's head he's got a he had a great job
in the media why did he take it
Doc's a coach though if you know Doc and
I'm sure you you do he would you know
watching film all hours of the night
wouldn't sleep like he's just it's in
his blood to Coach and he's great at
media as well so obviously you know we
all enjoy listening to him called games
but to his hard or heart he's a coach
and and not a bad you know situation to
walk into when you have two top 75
players of all time yeah but he's making
it seem like it's you know he's walking
into uh
Orlando yeah come on
no no he's walking into a great
situation that's for sure but he has to
make the situation work there's no doubt
about it I I got asked last night you
know has the the the struggles he's had
in the playoffs with the Clippers and
Philly and so on and so forth is that
going to follow him and I said it it
might follow him not that it's always
fair but it might follow him until you
know if he can get this right and win a
championship in Milwaukee I I think it
kind of you know qums everything in the
past how much does a coach
matter I think a coach matters Dan it's
no doubt if you look at the really
successful teams if you look at Phil
Jackson with Chicago and the Lakers you
look at you know SPO and in Miami you
look at Pat Riley you look at the greats
pop obviously in the Spurs Cur with the
Warriors coaching matters and it's not
always an ex's and O's it's bringing you
know people together it's accountability
it's it's different things and knowing
the post of your team so all those
different things going to it do you
think I could have won a title with the
bulls as a
coach DP I think you could have won a
title with Coach that's the correct
answer do I believe that you think I
could have won a title with sha and
Kobe I believe you could but could could
you have won a three peat no with both
those guys see that's coach they would
have gotten tired of
me that that that probably would have
happened but you know that eventually I
think magic talked about after a while
you know Pat Riley starts to wear on you
like you you can only be around that for
such I mean there's a a finite amount of
time it feels like you can put up with
each
other and I think that's a fact I think
that like even with the Clippers that
was the best team I was on I was there
five years the first year the second
year the jokes are funny we've heard the
stories are brand new they're fresh
right the third and fourth year he's
starting to finish the story's for
you're like okay we gotta get this we
gota we gotta win some games man forget
we got to try to win a championship
right and that's all of us I'm saying
players coaches everything like it
definitely wears on you who who was your
coach well I had I had a couple of them
I had Vinnie and I had doc at the time
as well okay so you had heard all their
stories yeah by the by the end I
definitely heard the stories I
definitely
did a man who put up 51 points and five
assists and is that right Paulie
confirmed
yeah yes Marvin with four different
teams what do you mean yes Marvin
yes Marvin go ahead speak on it Marvin
so Jamal Crawford the pride of Seattle
Washington scored 50 points with four
different
teams okay he was a bucket yeah he's the
jiss of the NBA
jiss there you go Marvin yep like he
might not be quote unquote a hall of
fame or whatever but you don't want to
guard him like you don't want to rap
against Jus and you don't want to guard
Jamal h of you don't want to guard him
you do not want to get in a cipher with
me on a song you do not want to get on
the same song
good to talk to you again Jamal thank
you you as well thank you DP appreciate
it Jamal Crawford always great to have
him on Sixth Man of the Year three times
scored over 50 points for four teams in
a game right Marv that is right yeah why
didn't you tell me that before we had
him on and then I I looked when Paul was
looking at it I looked at it up too I
was like four teams I thought he maybe
did it a couple times with the uh the
Knicks yeah little heads up little
research here could have helped me yeah
thank better never thank you m